[upbeat music]
- I mean, I guess I just
don't want to feel
like I'm being censored
in front of a client.
- No, no, no, and I don't
want you to feel that way.
I was just feeling a little off
'cause I kept forgetting
to call the fat kids "husky."
- [laughing]
That was so funny.
I mean,
you always call them fat.
- That's what they are.
[laughter]
Where is Sheila?
- [gasps] Tim, finally,
a mystery.
- Yes.
[Sheila laughing]
- Mystery solved.
- Yeah.
- Get me a box
of those pens I like.
Set me up with a massage
at 2:00.
And see if you can get
ahold of Emilio.
Have him come over
and measure me
for some new suits.
- You got it, Big Hank.
- Hey, Dad.
- Tim, Sam.
- They let you out?
- Of the nuthouse?
Yeah, got released
this morning.
[dramatic music]
♪ ♪
I'm back.
- You ain't shit.
- Never said I was.
- Well, you've implied it.